hey I'm Leticia and if you want to know
how to create a quick and easy glossy
look then carry on watching to start off
with I'm gonna use the pur Pro etienne
eyeshadow palette in the tone popular
and muddy and I'm just going to gently
buff that into the crease of my eye by
using warm tones this is going to add to
the dimension of your eyes don't worry
if you get any harsh lines because you
can use your finger to buck them out now
to create the glossy look I'm using a
lip gloss and I'm just going to spread
that all over the lid it's always best
to use a water-based lip gloss opposed
to the sticky one as after a while a
sticky one can become quite
uncomfortable moving on to lips I'm
going to start off by using a lip liner
so darken the outer corners I've decided
to use my eyebrow pencil as this is a
great tool to darken any lip liner to
complete the glossy look I'm going to
use the Laura Geller color luster lip
gloss this lip gloss has golden
particles in it this will make my lips
appear fuller and more Radio
if you want to see more videos like this
subscribe to the glamour UK